interesting because we see that also
with the like the plants and herbs and
spices that i mentioned with their
built-in plant defense mechanisms or
some of these centenarians who are
smoking like a cigarette a day
or or the the exposure to the radiation
from sunlight or the stress of heat or
cold like i was talking about it's kind
of like this concept of what's called
hormesis things that would be bad for
you in large amounts like alcohol which
is technically a toxin are actually good
for you in small amounts because like
exercise they beat up the body but the
body in the process of bouncing back
becomes stronger it builds more
antioxidants the cells become stronger
and so it's not an idea of living super
clean you know by living super clean you
can actually become a little bit more
weak it's about exposing your body these
mild stressors
how'd you get into all this stuff were
you always like this
uh no no i
i i wanted to be a computer programmer
growing up i love to like design video
games and you know tear apart my hard
drive and that's really what i wanted to
do i also you know i've
dude i was homeschooled i was president
of the chess club i played violin for 13
years i you know i wrote fantasy fiction
novels like i was a total nerd growing
up but uh what got me into like
nutrition
fitness physical culture in general was
i really fell in love with tennis when i
was about 14 years old and i just
started to look into like how you could
eat healthy to be a better tennis player
and i started to you know run the hills
behind my house and you know my dad
bought me a couple of 10-pound dumbbells
that i tried to learn how to use and
eventually i just got i got so into
tennis and how good fitness and eating
healthy seemed to make me that in
college i you know i studied um you know
biochemistry and biomechanics physiology
and and wound up just nerding out on on
just the entire science of the human
body and the human brain and you know
got a master's degree and all that and
and i've just been immersed
immersed in that science ever since
where does uh booze fit into all of this
are you doing any wine are you doing any
tequila
any anything well speaking of speaking
of blue zones most of those folks drink
yeah and for for men it's about two to
three drinks a day for women about one
to two drinks a day
but you gotta take into account the
nature of the alcohol right we're not
talking about margarita mixes and giant
fish bowl martinis we're talking about
like organic biodynamic wine grown in
soil that doesn't have a lot of water
added to it so it's less irrigated so
you got a higher concentration of
antioxidants because the grapes have
been beat up and a lower concentration
of sugars because there's less water or
you're looking at like you know
fermented compounds like uh you know
like kombucha for example you're looking
at clean burning uh higher alcohol
compounds like vodka or gin or tequila
often added to bitters and herbs and
spices so like for me personally i do at
the end of every day either a glass of
just like organic biodynamic wine and if
you don't know you're out at a
restaurant the three countries that
still do a pretty good job at that are
france italy and new zealand it's like
if you're going to order red out at a
restaurant you're pretty safe with those
three countries and then the other thing
that that i'll do if i'm not doing a
glass of wine is a very bitters forward
mix like i'll pour a glass of ice a
little sparkling water
put a shot of gin or vodka or tequila in
there and then just add bitters like
ginger or turmeric or lemon or lime or
even if i'm out at a uh out at a
restaurant and i'm ordering from the bar
i'll kind of glance through the cocktail
menu and choose something that's just
like a super bitters forward cocktail
and all occasionally you know if i'm
having a couple of drinks because it's a
long steakhouse dinner or something i'll
have my uh my glass of wine with my meal
but then leading up to that i'll just
have the uh the bartender just over the
rocks give me a selection of house
bitters with sparkling water and a
squeeze of lemon because those bitters
are actually really good for it that's
part of why alcohol can be good for you
but they also help you to digest your
food better and they even lower your
blood sugar response to a meal so so for
me it's usually like a real bitters
forward clean burning cocktail or a
glass of organic biodynamic wine and it
turns out that unless you have a
compromised liver or
um you know or you're unable to stop it
you know two or three drinks that
alcohol seems to have a little bit of a
life extending effect and it's
interesting because we see that also
with the like the plants and herbs and
spices that i mentioned with their
built-in plant defense mechanisms or
some of these centenarians who are
smoking like a cigarette a day or or the
the exposure to the radiation from
sunlight or the stress of heat or cold
like i was talking about it's kind of
like this concept of what's called
hormesis things that would be bad for
you in large amounts like alcohol which
is technically a toxin are actually good
for you in small amounts because like
exercise they beat up the body but the
body in the process of bouncing back
becomes stronger it builds more
antioxidants the cells become stronger
and so it's not an idea of living super
clean you know by living super clean you
can actually become a little bit more
weak it's about exposing your body to
these mild stressors you know a perfect
example that would be you know we know
that you know back to what we were
talking about before with not going to
the gym this concept of the hygiene
hypothesis
kids who grow up on farms and around
animals and with pets and who have been
exposed to lots of germs and bacteria
growing up they tend to have stronger
immune systems kids who drink raw
unpasteurized milk with all these
microbes and bacteria in it you know
which would just gross out or freak out
a lot of parents or people like they
tend to have lower incidence of asthma
and allergies because they're getting
exposed to these microbes and so that's
another perfect example of the things
that could crush you in large amounts
actually help your body to become
stronger in small amounts so so
alcohol's got a thumbs up in moderation
from the right sources right so from
alcohol where are you at with like weeds
psychedelics that kind of stuff i know a
lot of fitness people are sort of big on
weed right now even as part of the
workout routine
or regular yeah i just
i just interviewed a guy on my podcast
about this just the fascinating idea
behind the painkilling effect of like
thc and and cbd especially for endurance
athletes like ultra runners or
marathoners and also for people who are
in a painful sport like fighting or
football or hockey
um
it it seems like the use of cannabis
either for recovery or for pain killing
as an alternative to opioids or for
being able to just like get into the
zone and push through like low level
pain like ultra endurance running for
long periods of time seems to be
beneficial for that um
cannabis also of course has has a lot of
other beneficial effects for
inflammation it's wonderful for sleep
the problem of course is to be careful
with the addictive potential of it and
also most of the research shows that in
folks who are generally about under the
age of 18 there's a deleterious impact
on mental function cognitive function uh
you know
brain matter etc so be super careful if
you're young but there's there's not a
whole lot of issues with moderated
cannabis use kind of like alcohol for
adults and even exercising adults who
need it for kind of like the pain
killing or the focus effect
and then as far as the plant medicine
piece
look like i i think there's a ton of
efficacy to microdosing you're like
microdosing with psilocybin or
microdosing with lsd or microdosing with
san pedro or boga or whatever not only
for workouts and exercise but for
productivity for creativity for kind of
like merging of the left and right brain
hemispheric activity that allows for you
to think in different ways than you
might have otherwise and even
neurogenesis right the growth of new
neurons which particularly happens with
uh with psilocybin
and and for some people the ego
dissolution or the personal
uh professional or spiritual
breakthroughs that can occur with larger
doses on an infrequent basis like you
know some people go to an ayahuasca
journey or others will you know use a
higher dose of psilocybin um or you know
a whole combination of different plant
medicine compounds that can also be
pretty transformative the problem is
a lot of people will use that like
as an escape
um to just kind of kind of check out you
know take a whole bunch of psilocybin
and just lose control your body and
float off into bliss for a while to
escape the pain of life that you should
be confronting head-on and dealing with
in other ways or
they are um they're not doing the work
what's called the integration work
afterwards you know for me if i do a
plant medicine journey i have like four
or five days scheduled afterwards for
journaling for self-reflection for deep
work that doesn't involve the medicine
but that instead involves me just like
you know logging my thoughts and my
feelings and my breakthroughs and and a
lot of people and this is the reason why
you'll get folks doing like their 38th
ayahuasca retreat you know and they're
still the same person you talk to them
they're still searching you can see
until they're still incomplete etc it's
because
you know they're they're not doing the
work it'd be like
you know taking a taking a pre-workout
supplement
uh and and then sitting on the couch
right and not actually going to the gym
right so that's the problem is i find a
lot of people will use popping a pill
as an escape without actually wanting to
do the work and then in my opinion it
just turns into the same situation as a
drug addict you know he's just kind of
shooting up to feel good but never
actually benefits from the intended
purpose of that compound so
um so yeah for the most part there's a
lot of benefits to these to these type
of plant medicines it's just that um i
think most of the benefits are achieved
by proper use of of them via micro
dosing
and then and i have a whole section
about that in my book about how to
properly combine and stack these you
know as different microdoses for
productivity for creativity for sleep
etc and then for the larger journey
doses
i think it should be taken far more
seriously than people take it i mean the
like
for example what i mean by that is
let's say someone's going to journey
with plant medicines like deep and
actually use this as a breakthrough this
would be something you might do
during a rite of passage into adulthood
when you're 15 years old
with your
lover on your wedding night um
you know so that you can completely
dissolve all barriers and just be
sitting with them in full truth serum
for you know four to six hours on your
40th birthday and then maybe you know as
you approach your death in life for a
near-death experience to be able to
release a little bit of the fear of
death so maybe somebody might do this
like four to six times in a lifetime
right but a lot of people now they're
just like i'm journeying bro i'm on my
my second trip to south america this
year for ayahuas
these are these are pretty serious
things like you need to you know take
them seriously and acknowledge the
sacredness of these compounds and also
acknowledge the fact that
that that they're to be used in very
specific scenarios in a very ceremonial
setting and with a great amount of
intention and work afterwards and i just
don't see a lot of people using them in
that way if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're both right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell